well we were here at channel 8 very very
sad to report the passing of
jeopardy host alex trebek he died at the
age of 80 after battling pancreatic
cancer for nearly two years
and we really went on that journey with
him and tried to bring him messages to
her viewers
here's a look at the message jeopardy
will begin with
i'm mike richards the executive producer
of jeopardy
over the weekend we lost our beloved
host alex trebek
this is an enormous loss for our staff
and crew for his family
and for his millions of fans alex 30
seconds
he loved this show and
everything it stood for in fact he taped
his final episodes
less than two weeks ago
[Applause]
he will forever be an inspiration for
his constant desire to learn
his kindness and for his love of his
family
we will air his final 35 episodes as
they were shot
that's what he wanted on behalf of
everyone here at jeopardy
thank you for everything alex oh my
goodness
well trebek presided over the beloved
quiz show for more than 30 years
he was public in his battle with cancer
keeping his fans updated along the way
and his final
episode will air on christmas day
it's so hard to believe that he was in
the studio just two weeks ago and
i know the one thing that we talked
about yesterday was it seemed like this
was a really sudden turn
because it seemed like he was still
going
and doing his work and in the public eye
so recently you know ever since he
announced his diagnosis i remember we
aired the interview
that one there with jane pauley here on
cbs and others
he he looked so strong throughout and on
the new episodes of the program that
we've been watching
his uh the strength that he's shown
through the battle
with pancreatic cancer was just so
remarkable nate just uh
he's quite a man uh well you know brian
loftus had a chance to go down there and
record some of the episodes with james
holtz hour
and i believe there are some quotes from
mr trebek about how he would be an
excruciating pain but would gut it out
through an episode then go back to his
dressing room and i think he said it one
time she would ball up on the floor
but get up and do another episode gosh
it's such an aggressive cancer too
but he's such a role model and for i
think families to see him all this time
these several months just being so brave
and still continuing
as host it meant a lot so it's just sad
sad news
yeah i think brian said to him in their
exchange sitting together and talking he
said you
i don't think you realize how much
viewers really respect your strength
and your openness about going through
this and he said well
if i've done that for viewers and set an
example for anybody going through this
disease and cancer he said i
i'm really humbled by that so we wish
his family the very very best
and think of all the knowledge that he
brought to viewers through the years
i know i'm a little bit smarter for
jeopardy
and so enjoyed playing the game